What are the signs and symptoms of leaky gut?
Well, leaky gut
can cause all sorts of problems elsewhere in your body. So the signs and symptoms can vary greatly
depending on how bad leaky gut is.
The leaky gut is
where you have
particles of food that you've got. Anything that's in the gut,
passing into the bloodstream because
damage to the gut wall. So when you have damage to the gut wall, you can have
things get across the gut wall that should never get across the gut wall. So
perfect example would be proteins. I think if a protein is a lung chain of amino acids,
they're supposed to break down through enzyme activity in the gut
to very small chains of amino acids and then to single amino acids or a pair of amino acids
called a dipeptide. And that's the largest thing
as far as protein consumption that should cross the gut wall as a dipeptide.
Two amino acids connected together, mostly single amino acids across the gut wall.
And when you have damage to the gut wall or damage
to the cells themselves, you could get things crossing the gut wall that should never cross the
gut wall. The problem with that is that your immune system can react to those things.
And when your immune system reacts to those things, you can develop antibodies against those things.
And every time you eat that same food, you now you have antibodies in your bloodstream and antibodies
in the lumen of the gut that will fire an immune reaction against that peptide.
And when you do so, that causes a greater amount of inflammation and even greater amount of
damage to the gut wall. So it looks a cascade effect of the negative loop.
So symptoms can be varied from tummy aches to systemic inflammation to
rashes to brain inflammation to just the list goes on and on and on. Because when you have
inflammatory response, it's because of foods that you eat. Then every time you eat that food,
you're going to have this inflammatory response. And you have different gluteal morphine,
case-your-morphine receptors. And that's added to brain. You're going to cause inflammation of the brain.
And it looks quite replicative, probably also it's a gas system.
So you test for that. So you can test for that through what's called Syrex Array 2 test.
Syrex Array 2 tests for both kinds of leaky gut syndrome. You can get paracelular transmission,
paracelular damage. We need that's the most commonly described form of leaky gut where
you have things getting between the cells. The damage cells are causing the gap
between the cells. And therefore things are getting between the cells. Or you can have
transcellular conduction of material because the cells themselves are so damaged. That's a worse form
of leaky gut. And then later the final damage of leaky gut is when you end up developing antibodies
to like the polysaccharides. Which then will damage like the polysaccharide and
if anybody's going to do direct damage to the blood right there. So it gets more complicated
and gets more serious. So leaky gut isn't something to just pretend it doesn't happen.
You better be constantly dealing with it. So testing for it can be valuable or testable. It is
positive that you have to test for different foods and go down the line to to try to clean that up.
So it's a common scenario for most diseases. You could start in it. That's when people
spoke to some doctors say, every disease starts and they're going to get a lot of diseases
start in the gut. This is what we're talking about because you get this chronic inflammation.
You get things that pass the gut wall that should never have passed the gut wall. You get toxins
that should never have passed the gut wall. And then dig into the body. They can damage the body.
They get into the cells. They can damage the nucleus. They can be a cause of cancer.